If you have dollars in your wallet, just
know that money only has value because
of oil. And right now, the US is in
danger of getting tricked into a
protracted ground war with the very
country that controls the flow of a huge
chunk of the world's oil. If that
happens and they lose, the money in your
wallet becomes worthless and the
American empire dies. Not with a
whimper, but with a bang. At least
that's what one of the most viral
analysts on the internet, according to
Google Trends, told me yesterday in a
long- form interview. Despite being
almost entirely unknown just a few
months ago, this analyst has gone
hyperviral recently for predicting that
Trump would attack Iran. And I don't
mean that he made that prediction after
Trump bombed Fordo or even after he
started sending troops to the region. He
made that prediction back in May of
2024,
almost 2 years ago, before Trump was
even reelected. He stood in front of a
camera and his students and mapped out
Trump's reelection and the fact that he
would inevitably launch a war against
Iran with uncomfortable precision. He
laid out the justification, the trap
that's waiting for Trump, the unraveling
of an empire, and more beat by beat. His
name is Professor G. Young. And the
reason he could see all of this coming
when almost nobody else did is that he's
using a very specific framework that
you're going to want to understand that
has led him to some startlingly accurate
conclusions. In five parts, I'm going to
break down this framework, the stark
economic thesis that predicted this war,
its potential outcome, and what comes
next, as well as who the winners and
losers are likely to be, and how you can
prepare yourself for what's coming if
all of this comes true. Now, if you're
like me, section 4 is going to make you
mad, but it's worth understanding if you
want to know what's going on and how to
position yourself to win. Welcome to
part one, the framework that predicts
the future. In May of 24, Professor
Gang's lecture predicting this war had
fewer than a thousand views. When the
bomb started falling on Iran, however,
it went to a million views in just 72
hours. The world suddenly needed to
know, how did this guy see this coming?
Jang's framework combines three things.
Game theory, historical pattern
recognition, and something he calls
predictive history. Something that he
borrowed from Isaac Azimov, namely that
large-scale human behavior follows
structural patterns that repeat across
centuries. Not because people are
predictable, but because the economic
and geographic forces acting on them
are. strip away the personalities, the
ideology, the news cycle noise, and you
can see where things are actually
headed. That's how he called this war 2
years early. And that's the lens that
we're going to use right now. And our
first stop is 1971
when Nixon cut the dollar loose from
gold. The dollar should have collapsed,
becoming just another fiat currency
drowning in its own debt. But it didn't.
Instead, it was saved by one of the most
consequential backroom deals in modern
history. A one-two punch that rewired
the entire global economy and kept the
dollar indispensable, not by law, but by
structural necessity. The new system has
a name. We call it the petro dollar. And
Iran is the country that sits on top of
the one geographic choke point that can
bring the whole system to its knees. And
that's why every time you turn around, a
US president, not just Trump, is saying,
"We have got to do something about
Iran." When you've got a madman that
lives on the same street as your company
headquarters, and he's constantly waving
a gun around threatening your
livelihood, odds are you're going to
feel some type of way about that. And
when the only policeman in the world is
you, you're going to be tempted to act,
even if it needs to be violently to
ensure business remains good. the
company stays open and your dollars keep
flowing. That's what this war is
actually about. And once you understand
Iran is the madman at the end of the
street and you see it through that lens,
everything, the bombing of Ford Dao, the
ships in the straight, the desperate
scramble for a victory that keeps not
arriving. All of it, everything snaps
into focus. Here's how the petro dollar
actually works in practice. the Gulf
States, Saudi Arabia, the UAE, Kuwait,
and the rest of the GCC nations, they
sell their oil exclusively in dollars,
which means every country on Earth that
needs energy has to acquire dollars
first. Every country needs energy every
day. That structural demand is what
keeps the dollar positioned as the
world's reserve currency, even as
America runs deficits that would have
collapsed any other currency on Earth.
And crucially, those dollars do not just
sit in vaults in the Middle East. They
get put to work in the economy all over.
The Gulf States take their petro dollar
earnings and invest them. And for
decades, the most promising market in
the world was the US market. And the
safest bet, the thing literally known as
the risk-free rate of returns is US
Treasury bonds. So the GCC countries
poured money into US treasuries creating
a near endless demand for US debt. And
when the rate of return went too low,
the money flowed into US equity markets.
And recently that money has been
specifically flowing into US artificial
intelligence infrastructure and it
flowed in in massive quantities. When
Trump came back from his Middle East
tour early in year one of his second
term, he announced to much fanfare that
he had secured roughly two trillion
dollars in Gulf investment commitments
to the United States. Something that the
Gulf States have been doing anyway, but
they know to package it up as a gift.
The overwhelming majority of that money
was earmarked for AI data centers,
chips, the physical buildout of the AI
economy. That means that two of
America's most important economic
pillars, the petro dollar and the AI
infrastructure investments that we're
banking our entire future and economy on
are tied to money created by oil tankers
flowing through the straight of Hormuz.
I hope it's all starting to make sense
now. The very place being threatened by
the theocratic regime that waves its
guns around at the rest of the world
screams death to America and desperately
wants to disrupt the growing
relationship between the US, Israel, and
the GCC countries. Something that has
only been growing stronger with the
Abraham Accords, hence the October 7th
attack. Prior to Trump, everyone had
been willing to accept the fragile
stability in the Middle East. Keep your
head down. Keep the dollars flowing.
That was the mantra. You can sanction
Iran, but otherwise leave them alone.
But Trump just couldn't leave well
enough alone. Whether because he really
feared them becoming nuclear and taking
control of the strait, or because he was
feeling himself a little bit too much
after Venezuela, or because Israel wants
a war between Gog and Magog. More on
that later, or something else entirely.
Trump decided to launch the war. And
history provided us with a swift
reminder that the only law of history is
the law of unintended consequences. And
thusly the straight of Hormuz was
immediately shut down not by Iran but by
the insurance companies who feared Iran
would attack the ships. And they were
right. Make no mistake. This is why Iran
has always been the pressure point. Iran
doesn't need to beat the United States
military to win this war. All they have
to do is make the straight unusable.
Mines, drones, missiles, asymmetric
warfare that doesn't require a navy.
Just chaos. Disrupt the straight and the
oil stops flowing. The petro dollar
cracks, the Gulf States panic, and that
$2 trillion that was supposed to fund
the American AI economy, it goes into
defense instead. Here's what Jang's
framework showed him that so many other
people missed. The growing alliance
between Iran, Russia, and China create
an existential danger to the US,
especially because right now the US is a
declining empire. And when you combine
that with the incentives facing Iran,
plus the incentives of Israel and Saudi
Arabia, it becomes impossible for Trump
to stop himself from attacking Iran. I'm
going to break all of that down. First,
just understand not only did the
circumstances dictate that Trump was
guaranteed to attack Iran, the
circumstances guaranteed that it would
be impossible for him to win once he
did. Jang could see that for reasons
that are going to become incredibly
clear. The attack would cause Trump to
lose control of the very thing he was
trying to protect, the Straight of
Hormuz. Welcome to part two, the part of
history everyone has forgotten to
understand why Iran specifically is the
pressure point on the US and why it was
the pressure point on the British before
that and why in this moment the US was
guaranteed to attack. You need to
understand a piece of paper written by a
British geographer back in 1904. His
name was Halford Mckinder and what he
published in 1904 was one of the most
important and least talked about
strategic documents in modern history
and it continues to echo to this day.
Controlling behavior that most people
simply do not understand. Mckinder
looked at the world and saw something
that basically everybody had missed. For
centuries, the tiny island of Britain
had managed to dominate the globe by
ensuring that they had the largest navy
so that they could control the seas.
Given that trade happened on the seas
back in the day, it didn't matter how
big your country was. It mattered how
powerful your navy was. As an island
nation, Britain understood that that was
the only way for them to dominate the
world. And dominate they did. At their
height, they literally controlled all of
global trade. They controlled the open
sea, the shipping lanes, the choke
points, the ports. If you wanted to move
goods or armies, you had to put them on
a boat. And if you put them on a boat,
you had to deal with the British Navy.
But railroads were going to change
everything. And they knew it. For the
first time in human history, you could
move enormous quantities of goods and
soldiers across land faster than ships
could carry them by sea. And that meant
that whoever could unite the great
Eurasian landmass, the stretch of
territory running from Eastern Europe
through Russia through the Middle East
all the way to China would have access
to a combined pool of energy,
manufacturing capacity, and population
that no navy in the world could blockade
or stop. Now, Mckinder knew England's an
island, so it's got to have some
solution. Mckinder called this territory
the heartland. and his warning was
blunt. If any power ever manages to
unite it, the game is over for whoever
controls the seas. The seas just won't
matter anymore. Britain's response was
to make sure that nobody ever united the
heartland by any means necessary. Fund
wars, back opposing factions, keep
Europe and Asia divided and at each
other's throats, force commerce back
onto the water where the British Navy
could control it. the Napoleonic Wars,
which most people think of as a story
just about French ambition. It's that,
but in large part, it was about Britain
spending enormous amounts of blood and
treasure to make sure France didn't
unify continental Europe. Same with
Russia's attempts to push towards warm
water ports. Same with backing the
Ottoman Empire to keep Russia contained.
Every major British geopolitical move
for 150 years was a variation on that
same theme. Prevent Eurasian
unification. Keep the heartland divided.
Then when the British Empire was simply
too battered, bruised, and indebted
after World War II, they were forced to
pass the baton onto the new great power,
the United States. and America
understood the playbook and they have
been running the exact same method ever
since. Different tools, sure, but same
objective.
We will get right back to the show in a
second. But first, let's talk about
surviving holiday travel and snacks. You
can't control your holiday travel.
Flights get delayed, plans fall apart,
you end up stuck in some airport
terminal watching the clock while your
only food options are overpriced.
Garbage. That's why I always travel with
Paleo Valley beef sticks in my bag. They
are not only an insurance policy,
they're a fantastic snack, and they stop
me from getting stuck somewhere hungry
with only terrible options. Most people
cave when they're hungry, desperate.
They just basically are willing to
compromise at that point to eat
something, anything. I do not want that
to happen to me. These beef sticks are
100% grass-fed, grass-finished beef, six
grams of protein, zero sugar, no
artificial preservatives, and don't let
holiday travel derail your health. Be
prepared for the holidays. Get up to 35%
off your order. Click the link below to
save. And now, let's get back to the
show.
Do not let Mckinder's Heartland get
united. Then it keeps everything on the
seas. And when you're the US and you're
far away from Asia and you're far away
from Europe, now all of a sudden you
keep everything on the oceans where you
with your major navy can control the
entire globe. Now with that in mind,
look at the BRICS partnership. Look at
Iran and China through that lens. Look
at Venezuela and its Chinese oil
shipments through that lens. Look at
Trump's attempts to seduce Russia away
from China through that lens. Russia and
China are already aligned. Russian
energy, Chinese manufacturing, two of
the three legs of a potential heartland
alliance already connected. The US knows
that the thing Mckender spent his entire
career warning the world about is
already halfbuilt. Iran is the third
leg. Geographically, Iran is the
keystone. It's the bridge between
Russian energy to the north, Chinese
manufacturing to the east, and the oil
fields of the broader Middle East to the
south and west. It anchors China's Belt
and Road Initiative, the network of
land-based trade routes that Beijing has
been building for years, specifically to
reduce dependence on, you guessed it,
sealanes. Sea lanes that the US Navy
controls. But Iran is far weaker than
the other two. So, if you're the US and
you're looking for a target, your eyes
go right to Iran. But if they could
secure a nuclear weapon, they would no
longer be the weak link. A nuclear armed
Iran that can shake off US sanctions,
bully the region, and cooperate with
Russia and China is a force powerful
enough to potentially unite the
heartland, and relegate the US to a far
less dominant role on the global stage.
When you're the reserve currency, that
is existential. This is exactly what
Mckinder spent his career warning about.
A connected Eurasian land mass that
routes around naval power entirely. And
with a land-based alternative in place
and a weaker US, the GCC no longer
benefits from the protections that the
US is currently providing. And that
would render the petro dollar
meaningless. Once that structural demand
for the petro dollar disappears, the
US's power is weakened even further.
That is why the United States launched
an attack on Iran. A nuclear armed Iran
is not only a danger to the US, Israel,
and the GCC countries, but it's also the
final piece in a completed heartland
alliance that is truly an existential
threat to the entire architecture that
gave birth to American power. But if
Jang's framework is correct, it's
already too late and the US will not be
able to win this war. So the question
becomes, did attacking Iran simply
trigger a trap? Welcome to part three.
It's a trap. Every president for the
last 40 years sanctioned Iran,
threatened Iran, and then ultimately
left them alone. There was a reason for
that. And Trump just found out what it
was. The US has enemies in this
conflict. That's obvious. But according
to Jang, what's not obvious and what
makes this unlike any war the US has
fought in recent memory is that some of
America's most important allies actually
want America to enter this war
specifically because they believe
America will lose. Let's start with
Saudi Arabia. On the surface, the Saudis
and US are allies. They sell oil and
dollars. They park their money in
American markets. They share the US's
desire for a weakened Iran. Now, all
that is true, but zoom out and ask what
Saudi Arabia actually wants in the long
run. They want to be the dominant power
in the Middle East. A nuclear Iran is an
existential threat to that for sure. So,
yes, they want Iran destroyed, but a
United States that decisively wins this
war and plants a flag permanently in the
region, that's not in Saudis best
interests. The Saudis have been quietly
building relationships with China.
They've been floating the idea of
pricing some oil in yuan. They want
options. A dominant entrenched America
in their backyard shuts down some of
those options. So, the ideal outcome for
Riad is a wounded Iran and a distracted,
overextended America that needs Saudi
cooperation more than ever. They want
the US in this war. They just don't want
the US to win it cleanly. Israel's
calculus is more complex and definitely
more unsettling. There are powerful
factions within Israeli leadership who
view this conflict explicitly in
biblical endof days terms. Giang is
direct about this in a way that most
analysts just refuse to talk about.
Admittedly, it sounds pretty crazy, but
these factions want Iran destroyed, not
weakened, destroyed. But some of them
also believe that unchecked American
imperial power is ultimately an obstacle
to what God intends to unfold in the
region. And they are pushing politically
to make sure that America is not going
to be there in the end. Much like Saudi
Arabia, they want the US's help to
weaken Iran. But for the biblical
prophecies to come true, the US must be
out of the picture for the war of Gog
and Magog to take place and fulfill
God's will for his chosen people, the
Israelites. So according to Jang, they
have encouraged and cajol the US into
entering the war, but ultimately once
Iran is sufficiently weakened, they want
the US to be forced to retreat due to
domestic political pressure. Something
that seems pretty likely to happen if
ground troops are used. That's the trap.
America enters a war that its closest
allies helped engineer against an enemy
that believes it's fighting for its very
survival. And it is in terrain that
neutralizes almost every advantage the
US military has once they go in on the
ground. Jung notes this kind of thing
has happened in history before. In 415
B.CE, TE Athens assembled the most
powerful naval expedition the ancient
world had ever seen and sent it to
conquer the much weaker Sicily. The navy
was so dominant and so confident that
defeat genuinely seemed impossible.
Sound familiar? However, every ship that
left never came home. The expedition was
annihilated and the Athenian Empire, the
greatest military force of its age,
never recovered. for the trap to work.
Iran doesn't need to win. They just need
to drag the US into a war of attrition
like we got drugged into in Iraq and
Afghanistan. Now, this is something
Trump swears he'll never do, but only
time is going to tell. Welcome to part
four, the part that's going to make you
mad. Now, I warned you about this
section because here's where Jang's
framework stops being a geopolitical
history lesson and starts being a story
about your money, your job, and your
future. The old world doesn't end with a
single catastrophic explosion. It ends
through a chain of connected failures.
Each one making the next that much more
likely. And in no small part, due to the
war with Iran, that chain reaction is
already in motion. Imagine it. The war
drags on. The straight stays closed or
just too dangerous for normal commercial
shipping for an extended period of time.
The GCC countries, the same ones that
pledged $2 trillion into American AI
infrastructure, now they have a problem.
Their own oil infrastructure and water
infrastructure are at risk. Their
populations are nervous and they have a
very simple decision to make. Do we keep
buying US debt and funding the American
AI economy, or do we fund our own
defense and ensure our survival? It's a
pretty simple decision to make. And at a
certain point, if Iran still poses a
threat, the GCC countries will redirect
all of their capital towards their
survival. And that's when the US economy
really goes boom, and not in a good way.
When the GCC money that has been feeding
our economy in ever growing amounts for
decades now suddenly stops flowing into
America, not only does the appetite for
US debt, the debt appetite that's
required to fund our reckless spending,
not only does that cease, but the AI
bubble will also burst. Because right
now, AI valuations are not based on
current revenues. They're based on the
promise of future revenues that are
expected to come. But only if we
actually finish this AI infrastructure
buildout and the revenues get delivered
because AI just keeps getting better and
better. If it stalls out now, we've got
a problem. Remember, AI companies are
now talking about building in outer
space. If you pull the capital flow, the
math collapses. And if that last part of
the US economy breaks, it's going to be
devastating. The American economy is
already in a horrific K-shaped
situation. Most people are struggling to
make ends meet and the only people that
are spending are the people at the top
of the K. And they're able to spend
because all of the GCCF fueled money is
flowing into the market. If that stops,
now the top of the K and the bottom of
the K are in trouble. The top of the K
right now is creating an illusion that
the consumer economy is basically
functional. But without GCC dollars
creating demand for that debt and
private investment into the AI industry,
those spenders too are going to feel the
pinch and the economy is likely to
violently implode. Add on top of that
the fact that foreign governments and
central banks are already selling US
Treasury bonds because they're not dumb.
They're looking at our debt, which is
absolutely reckless. out of control and
insane. And if they all abandon the US
debt market at the same time, things
could get dark, really dark for a long
time. And that is exactly how empires
die. Slowly at first and then all at
once. But as always, in times of massive
disruption, there is always massive
opportunity. So, welcome to part five,
the new world order. If all of this
comes to pass, what comes next? And how
do you position yourself to win? This is
a part where most analysts just throw up
their hands and they say, "Nobody
knows." Jung disagrees strongly. What
comes after the petro dollar is a world
shaped by three forces. And these aren't
policy choices that leaders are going to
get to make. It's just what happens when
the machine that held the old world
together stops working. The first is
de-industrialization.
The global economy we've all grown up in
was built on cheap, stable energy from
the Middle East. Urban centers flourish.
Global supply chains move smoothly. The
knowledge economy, AI, all of it, all of
it is downstream of affordable oil. When
energy becomes expensive and unreliable,
the model inverts. Local resilience
beats global efficiency. Nations have to
rebuild more self-sufficient economies.
That's painful, sure, but it's coming
regardless. At least according to Xiang.
The second inevitability is
mercantalism. The global free trade
order required a guarantor, a cop
willing to enforce the rules all over
the world. In the scenario that we've
been discussing, the US will no longer
have the economic ability to act as the
world's police force. Even if they want
to do it, they're not going to be able
to do it because without that appetite
for their debt, they can't deficit
spend. You have to balance your budget.
You can't be a world cop with a balanced
budget. Things will once again be forced
to be regional. Regional powers will
emerge. Countries will become more
self-sufficient. Nations will
increasingly start acting in their own
self-interest. Regional trading blocks,
local supply networks. The era of
frictionless global commerce is over. At
that point, the third is
remilitarization. Pax Americana is
ending. When there's no global guarantor
of security, every nation that wants to
survive has to be able to defend itself.
The nations that refuse to face that
reality will be absorbed or coerced by
the ones that do. In Jang's view,
America's decline does not lead though
to a Chinese rise, as many people will
assume. This is one of the more shocking
predictions that he makes. According to
Jang, China is optimized for the old
world order, and that order is ending.
China's entire economic model was
engineered for global supply chains,
western capital, and stable Middle
Eastern energy. The new world breaks all
three simultaneously.
China wants to trade its way to
dominance, but in the new world that
will be impossible. Japan of all places
is Jang's pick for the regional power in
Asia. Now, it's beyond the scope of this
topic to explain why, but you can watch
my full interview with Jang where we
cover this in detail. Europe, as we
understand it today, in Jang's
assessment, is also toast. They
outsource their energy to Russia and
their military to America, and they're
going to find themselves perpetually at
risk in the new world order. And the
United States doesn't disappear. It
contracts, becomes a Western Hemisphere
power. Still formidable, but no longer
the world's enforcer. As for the Middle
East, if their theologies hold true, and
God really returns, then all bets are
off. Otherwise, the dominant power there
will be determined by how things turn
out with Iran. The new world is not
going to be a world ruled by one great
power. It's going to be ruled by several
regional powers, each dominant in their
own sphere, none strong enough to set
global rules, more contested, more
dangerous with no shared rule book. So
now, what do you do with this
information? First, and I cannot stress
this enough, please don't panic. The
goal of stepping inside of Professor
Gang Young's frame of reference is to
understand the framework that helped him
see what so many other people missed.
It's not to send you screaming into a
bunker. It's to help you assess more
potential outcomes so you can make
better decisions based on first
principles and cause and effect and have
a broader view than the people around
you who are stuck inside of a narrative
that was almost certainly handed to them
by somebody else. not something that
they thought through after evaluating a
bunch of perspectives. Now, here's how
I'm thinking about all this. The economy
right now is weak. It's certainly
fragile. Optionality is king. I am
trying to keep updating my assumptions
all the time based on where things are
trending. The more options I have mapped
out ahead of time and the triggers that
indicate which option I should pursue
when, the better off I think I'm going
to be. Most financial and career plans
are built on the idea that the world
basically keeps working the same way
that it always has. People assume that
the dollar is going to stay strong, that
US markets will recover over time. But
for the first time in a long time, that
may not be true. But it's still unknown.
Global supply chains may stay intact or
the straight of Hormuz may stay closed
for months or even years. So build
resiliency into your strategy. Start
considering a world that is more local
than global. What would that look like?
Consider what works in a world with
shorter, more local supply chains.
Contemplate what holds value regardless
of what the dollar does. Think about
assets that aren't someone else's
liability. Be more skeptical of debt
than ever. The people who navigate this
transition best are not going to be the
ones who predict exactly what's going to
happen. They're going to be the ones
that never allow themselves to have a
single point of failure. Now, as always,
pay attention to energy. It is
absolutely foundational to everything.
Be positioned to weather energy price
shocks that are almost certainly going
to keep going for a while. And stay
liquid enough to have options. The one
thing even Buffett and Dalio agree on is
optionality. Don't be so locked into a
single bet that you can't move when a
clear picture of the future begins to
take shape. And as a final reminder, I
think Professor Gang is a phenomenally
interesting thinker running a framework
with high predictive validity, but
humans and economies are far too
complicated to get overly confident in
any one framework. Don't forget to
routinely zoom back out and update your
mental model. All right. If you want to
see me explore ideas like this in real
time, be sure to hit that subscribe
button right now and join me Monday,
Wednesdays, and Fridays at 7 a.m.
Pacific, where you can chill in the
community or join in the debate. All
right, until next time, my friends, be
legendary. Take care. Peace. If you like
this conversation, check out this
episode to learn more. The structure of
the market is changing rapidly and it is
creating a massive financial opportunity
for anyone paying attention. The last
time this happened, an entire new group
of million